Now if you've been actively thinking about how threads work so far
in this lesson, you may be wondering how does the memory for a
thread get cleaned up after it is finished, or where does its return
value go, or how can I make sure the thread has finished its
work before I let the main thread terminate? We'll answer all these
questions by looking at the distinction
between joinable and detached threads. Let's start
by talking about what makes a thread terminate. We'll draw the main thread
here on the left, our thread here on the right. And maybe there
are some other threads in between. There are really
two cases. First, the entire process will terminate if
any thread makes a call to exit or if main reaches the end of its code, it's or
executes a return statement. Again this will kill all
threads associated with the process. The second way our
thread might terminate, is if he himself calls either
pthread-exit or executes a return statement. The distinction between
joinable and and detached threads is important for the second case
here. A thread can either be created in a detached state, or
detached later with the procedure call. When the detached thread reaches
the end of its execution, its memory is cleaned up right away,
and any return value just disappears. At least, no other thread
has a way of getting at it. Moreover, we have to be
careful that main doesn't reach the end of its execution, and
execute a return statement, before the thread is done with its work.
As seen in point 1, if main returns, then
the whole process terminates. So if we want to keep
this detached thread going, we have to terminate main
with a special call to pthread exit. Joinable threads, y
contrast, don't get destroyed right away when they finish.
Instead, they stick around until another thread joins them. This
other thread makes a call to thread join, specifying
the thread. And also an address where the return value
of the joinable thread will get stored. This call blocks,
until the joinable thread is finished. Though it's okay too
if it's finished already. So it's okay for the joined
call to be made first. Before the join thread is
finished. Having main join with other threads is a common
way to make sure that main doesn't finish before the
other threads, and kill them all via exit method one.
By default, threads are joinable in the p threads library.